then there's these doctors
basically they take care of people
and the female doctors are better
how do you know that they're better
because the people that they're treating are less likely to die
and they live longer
well I've said those doctors must get treated really well
no they get treated worse what
yeah okay
so female doctors are less likely to be promoted
because they're more likely be discriminated against because they're women
if women doctors are better
why would it be bad to be
I know
okay so if they're better at their jobs and they get treated worse
they must get paid more
no I get paid the same
no what happens
like a lot less
should I go no no
don't go we have made so many advancements on women's health
and at least you're not paying those doctors less
because they're working on women